[Music]
pamela becker thank you so much for
being with me on 20 minute leaders
well thank you for having me so good to
have you
i'm working from home i'm one of those
working from home people
um forced by corona yes
one of the hundreds of millions yes
definitely okay so pamela a huge history
of
marketing at amazing companies uh
just notably iron source now prove many
others along the way
you authored a book a very successful
book you funded a charity
and talk to me a little bit about your
your journey so far
and and talk to me a little bit about
marketing let's start over there
what is it about marketing that
attracted you and and how do you see
your role
as vp of marketing of a company like
proof
well okay so i guess um
where did i start off you know about a
million years ago when i
graduated college with a degree in
creative writing to me it's all about
storytelling you know i love writing
stories
and i was really good i wrote five short
stories that got published in magazines
that were reputable
and i earned a total of twenty five
dollars
so um i then realized
um i was going to have to if i if i
didn't want to be
you know if i wanted to eat i was going
to have to find a way
to take that storytelling love of mine
and find a new
way to express it and that is one of the
reasons why i went into marketing i
started
in in public relations moved to
advertising
and then became either the in-house or
um
um outsourced marketing director of like
you said a lot of israeli
leading tech companies um particularly
in the whole ad tech and
fintech space um so to me
yeah to me it's all about the story when
i
when i enter a new company
i try and understand what is their story
how do we frame that story
what is the story and sometimes the
story the company story is not really a
great story
sometimes we have to kind of think about
what is the story we want to tell
what do you do at that point you enter a
company and you're like guys listen this
is not a great story
let's let's reinvent it let's rethink
how we portray ourselves
um you know what you would be surprised
at how much resistance there is
generally there's a lot of resistance
there's like but this is who i am
and there's that whole conversation
about
you know do you tell people what you
want to say
or do you tell people what they're open
to here
and and that's really a real mind
switch and you um and a lot of a lot of
executives
that i've worked with in the past it
takes it takes some time for them to get
used to the idea of wait a minute wait a
minute but i have to tell them this
and i forgot to tell them and they go on
and on about something
that even even their business partners
want to are like taking a nap by the
time they're done
i think that's fascinating you know i
actually just yesterday i had a class at
the stanford business school
where we were talking about frank klutz
i don't know if you know him
but he he invented something called the
word lab
where he helped political candidates for
presidents in the u.s
he would take focus groups and he would
start saying phrases and he would
measure their heart rate and their eye
rolling as he said
certain words because he discovered that
politicians shouldn't say
what they think people want to hear they
should say really what people want to
hear not what they
want to say so really along the same
line i love all these connections
okay so so you go to these companies and
you're reinventing the story
what what is the talk to me about the
connection between
the creative writing in college or
writing stories in general
and going to them to do marketing
because it's not exactly the same thing
right
um yes and no because um listen if
you're a frustrated artist as i was
you know you do need that kind of outlet
you know yes mom i'm not good enough to
make it as a professional writer but
look i have a career
um so uh um
look and i'm not saying oh i write
beautiful
copy just to make my my heart better
do you know what i mean to serve myself
but there is something
and i think that as a creative person
and as a marketing person and then also
we talked about i have a charity as well
it's all about impact and so for me
it's not just about telling the story
but you want to tell a story
that has some kind of impact or effect
whether it's making the business go from
here to here
or from changing people's minds from
here to here or or what or just kind of
touching them in a way that they haven't
been touched before
so so so to me that is that it's all
it's all kind of the same
so and how does that thinking of
impact go coincide with you know fintech
and adtech because
you know usually fintech and netflix
aren't necessarily the most
humane impactful industries i would
imagine more education healthcare
so how do you find the balance over
there okay
so i didn't say that it was necessarily
an impact to making the world a better
place
i didn't think that that was the impact
well that's definitely your charity
yeah we all have we all you know we do
what we can
when we can and where we can and um and
and when i'm in a business environment
the impact i may want to make
is helping this company become more
competitive um
uh make make sure that they are the
company when if it's very competitive
not just to get clients but to get
employees how to
how to how to position themselves and
again we talked about storytelling
and having that impact in terms of you
know
um impacting how other potential
partners
um clients and investors feel about them
no no but actually but actually pamela
you are trying to make the world a
better place and you are making an
impact through your charity which is
complementary then to your to your work
and and marketing so
talk to me a little bit about this
charity and and also about this this
book that you wrote
okay so um uh jeremy circle
is a non-profit um what we do
is we support children and teenagers who
are growing up
in in homes where that have been touched
by cancer and
what we mean by that is their children
that either there's a parent or a
sibling that
has cancer now or that they've
experienced a cancer loss
um we i co-founded uh
jeremy circle that's the name uh
12 years ago with my late husband's
sisters i'm sad to say that
jeremy was my husband and
it came about because when he was first
diagnosed with um
stage four cancer
our children we had three children six
months
four and six i believe
um and um you're you're freezing
can you hear me i'm i'm with you um it
says
you're with me so okay so when he was
first diagnosed our children we had
three children
one was six months i believe one was
four one was six
um and uh we were we were really
i mean my husband was a very special guy
um and he would oh he would talk about
how lucky we were
i didn't feel so lucky but he felt lucky
um
that we had these friends and family
that would support us in a way
by taking our children out so that we
could have
some quiet time they would take our
children out um so
instead of them being stuck in front of
a tv at home or me
yelling at them which is probably what
would have happened um
they took them to barbecues or on hikes
or did whatever they would have done
with their with their own kids um and
that was basically how um how most of
our weekends went
during during his entire illness so
afterwards we we founded jeremy circle
which is which now supports 700 families
throughout
israel 700 families 700 young
families we have programs what we we do
fun days for the families um and we do
programming just for the teenagers
because we know that
you know parents are uncool when you're
a teenager and so
it's more fun when the parents don't
come so
um so that's what we do and uh and
that's our that's jeremy circle yes
wow so that was 12 years ago and so
you're you're working full-time in
marketing and you have three children
and this horrible illness comes and and
takes over
and how do you even deal with that i
mean
so i i it sounds and i'm very fortunate
to not have gone through
a tragic experience and myself with that
sword and
um and i'm sorry for your loss but it
sounds like a lot of people either get a
lot of resilience from it and a lot of
inspiration to go and do something about
it
like you did and some others don't and
they rather
you know just continue with their life
and and and go along talk to me a little
bit about this time period
and what's going through your head and
how does this idea of jeremy circles
come about
okay i deal with things as i do stuff
you know some people when they're
yes i lost you for that one sentence can
you just start that one over
okay so i guess i'm one of those people
that the way i i cope
is i do stuff you know some people
they want to you know just let me be
or i have or take me take me someplace
else
but um for me i have this
this um motto you know that uh
helping is healing um and
i guess i mean we in we had talked
earlier
um uh we had talked at some point about
reinventing
the importance of reinvention and
reinventing yourself and
i found often when my husband was sick
and it was no secret right
um and people would look at me here i am
with an infant
and come going into the um oncology ward
with my husband in a wheelchair um
i got those looks and i hated those
looks and for me um one of the things
that i
uh one of the ways i coped was changing
the subject
which is a lot of if you go back to
marketing you know with crisis
management you always
that's that's another thing that you do
but for me
um for me it was all about changing the
subject so
whether when he was his sickest i would
just be like oh i'm running a marathon i
ran
x amount of kilometers today and they'd
be like uh
want to deal with the with those those
looks i didn't want to deal with
people feeling sorry for me um and so
um when when um after he
um when he was at his sickest it was a
few weeks before he died
um we were in the hospital and he talked
about that maybe we should create this
organization
and we sat down and started you know um
and again he was also one of these
people that does things we sat down in
the hospital
and instead of being like moaning oh woe
is me what was me i feel so sorry for
myself
which other people in his position had
all the right to do of course but
instead
we sat there in the hospital and wrote a
business plan
and put together a program together with
his sister he has a sister who
has um she is a psychologist and a
sister who
is a computer specialist and we put
together a plan
and it kind of just kept things on on a
level that
expressed we could express all our pain
and our frustration but in a positive
way
and put it in a positive direction and
then after he passed away
people started asking me oh what you
know i want to plant a tree in his name
what is his favorite charity
and i said you know what we're just
going to start this we're going to try
and do it
um we um
and so we we found someone to help us
with the paperwork so
we would have a place where people could
give donations
um are and and we just started our first
event had 25 families
and i'll tell you at that first event
which was
a hanukkah event it was in december of
2008 so it was
he passed away in july so it was not
that far after he
that long after he died and um
these these children are playing um
they're um
they're in these sumo wrestler outfits
you know when you put these little
children in these big funny outfits and
they
do this to each other i don't know and
um
and and i'm watching and it's so funny
and we've got like the dj that came as a
volunteer and the music's going it's a
great event
and the mother is standing there and
she's crying and she says to me and i
said to her why are you crying she goes
this is the first time this is the
i'm sorry um this is the first time that
i've seen
him i've seen him let loose and have fun
in months and we understood then that
we that there was something about
getting these kids together
that they're all in these very stressful
situations but when they get together
um and they know that the other kids are
in the same situation and if one's
having fun then it almost gives the
other one permission to permission to
have fun
right and and it was one of those things
like we were like you know what this
can't be a one-off
we have to keep doing that and that was
12 years ago
unbelievable so 12 years ago you started
with 25 families and now you have over
he said 700 families in this network
that are going to these jeremy's circles
events
yes but again like i said we are always
thinking
like um as a marketing person as a
um as anyone where we have to reinvent
ourselves
this year what are we going to do we
can't invite 300
children who all come from families that
are immun
immune immunizatio whatever it is
suppressed
immune suppressed um we can't put them
in a
we can't put them in a closed space
together so
so we've been reinventing ourselves
we've been sending um what we call fun
kits to the families with all sorts of
games and puzzles and jump ropes and
whatever
and we are now planning for the summer
what should we do because
we have to you know it's it's an
evolution we
who we were in who we will be in 2021 is
very
different than who we were in 2019
oh 100 and you touched upon this a few
times now but this idea of reinventing
yourself
and constantly thinking okay innovation
is not just in the aspect of business
but it's also in the aspect of our
personal lives and constantly as we go
through struggle and adversity
and world adversity we have to continue
thinking and innovating
how do you how do you surround yourself
with this sort of creativity
and this inspiration to go and do that
because sometimes you have to do it
alone which is very very hard
i think it's just a question of i don't
know i think it was brad pitt
who very very um specifically
said in the classic
world war zed he said you know you have
to keep moving or die
you know um i think that's
i think that that's it i think that if
we don't keep moving if we don't keep
evolving if we don't keep changing
a it may be a little boring and b
we uh we stop growing we stop
um you know who wants to be the same
person they were five years ago i
certainly don't
you know um so
so i do think we have to continue
constantly look like
you know what do i want to be when i
grow up even as you know i'm pretty old
but
i'm still asking it 100 100
so you know you are a marketing expert
and and while
i mean our talking about jeremy circles
was
so much more fascinating than than so
then i think anything we could say about
anything business related but in any
ways tell me
one or two earned secrets that you've
earned over the years about marketing
as you approach these new marketing
challenges which are new constantly
what are some of the key things that you
feel like you've earned
you know on your skin on as you had skin
in the game over the years
i think i think like i said just like
with anything else in life
i think there is tremendous value in
changing the subject
i don't know if it's in marketing i
don't know if it's in a meeting
i don't know if it's um in a press
release
but if someone is talking about
something that you don't want to talk
about
talk about what you want
just change the subject you're in charge
you know
move the conversation and i think that
this is something in marketing that is
so
important you decide if somebody keeps
saying to you
but but why is it raining and you're
like but
look at the sea and they're like but why
is it raining and you're saying but the
sea is gorgeous somebody they're going
to eventually understand they're going
to leave that conversation and be like
let's go to the beach you know what i
mean so
i do i think that i think that sometimes
i think that
the most important thing that i learned
first as a pr professional and then
in high tech and and building and
building them and trying to
building these marketing plans and so on
and so forth is that if you want to be
in you have to take charge of
of the conversation too it's it's not
just changing the subject when it
doesn't uh
when it doesn't suit you but take charge
of it you know
no no definitely yeah and there are
certain tricks to that
there are certain tricks and like um
focusing
on one clear message and sticking
doing it over and over again reinvention
it's all about reinvent see
i just did it so you know that kind of
taking charge of the conversation
understanding that um
it's better to get one good strong idea
across
well and then reinforcing it than trying
to throw
a whole bunch of different things at
people and expect them to remember after
they've eaten dinner and then their kid
jumped on their head and then
you know um something broke a hundred
percent now you know
as you're saying this i i keep thinking
about you know
the daily press releases that we have
here in the united states
with the government and some of these
tactics that we're seeing employees
it's interesting to see that and i think
i'm going to start using some of these
with my own girlfriend
so i'll report back to to how things
went when she's upset with me
and changing the conversation okay
pamela right before we leave
okay no no go ahead what go ahead no
okay but no no no i'm not getting
involved between you and your girlfriend
i've decided against it why now i'm
gonna stay right here i'm staying right
here
now if something bad happens i can just
say but pamela told me so she's an
expert in marketing
um and then as you say you're not
selling me anything honey we're partners
oh there you go there you go i love it
okay pamela right before we go
um i need three words that best describe
you
i'm especially curious to hear your take
on this three words
that you would either describe yourself
or that your kids would describe you as
or your
co-workers um or jeremy sisters
um okay we're going to go back to that
reinvention
love it um we're going to talk about
we're going to say storyteller
we didn't talk about my book but um
storyteller
and uh um
[Music]
and as my third it's hard
i would say
giving i love it i love it by the way
pamela did that book make more than 25
um it did make more than 25 but it did
not make more than what i spent at the
um
when i made a little party at my house
to celebrate
so i don't know how we break even but uh
we'll call it a great success we'll call
it a nice closure to the university
times
it's a huge success a huge
go buy it now okay there you go all
right pamela thank you so so much for
the inspiration
really amazing stuff all of all across
the board
and and i can't wait to share this with
everybody thank you
thank you very much okay bye bye